hey folks welcome to the Darkhorse
podcast live stream Thanksgiving Eve
edition episode number 200 not prime
divisible by 150 25 20 10 8 5 4 2 and
one if I am correct you just did that in
your in your head right before we came
on I did I'm proud of myself it's not a
difficult problem but I I think I nailed
all the
factors I don't know I haven't thought
about it all right well uh 1 two 4 5 8
10 20 25 50
100 maybe I think it is um let's put it
this way if it's not we will know
shortly after the podcast ends and our
next live stream I will deliver not only
a correction but an apology an apology
and who in this case will the apology be
to uh to mathematics and everything that
depends upon it wow global apology a
global AP Universal apology I would say
indeed yeah all right number 200 it's
big wow 200 who thought wild seems like
a lot of it does it does okay so join us
on Rumble if you're uh if you're
watching live and uh if you're watching
live also join us on locals for the
watch
party um we have lots of stuff going on
at locals we have our private Q&A this
Sunday at 11:00 a.m. Pacific we've got
um early release of guest episodes of
Darkhorse amas sometimes got the Discord
available there so please join us there
uh we are going to be talking today
about equity and infant care that sounds
like something important that we should
all be interested in fostering it's not
but infant Equity foster care that's
what I'm thinking yeah okay well we will
get there soon um workplace
toxicity workplace tox you're talking
about the off gassing of workplace
Furniture is that uh God I wish I was
actually
all right kind of oh yes uh 40 you
missed 40 nice W five five by 40 I will
that wasn't even me you can imagine who
that was who yes you can imagine I will
um I will need to prepare my uh my
correction and apologies so that's still
going to take time so it seems to me
that a simple turn turn your page back
so I can see your factors um you could
have just counted the number of factors
you had and if you had an uneven number
uh it seems to me here's the thing I did
it in such a rush yeah in matching up
the factors I missed one yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay yeah all right all right um it
is what it is it happens you know the
thing is we we don't like to have to
make such admissions but it is far
better to admit that you were wrong Sam
Harris than to go on being wrong Sam
Harris we're also going to talk about
gratitude and Thanksgiving speak of
things that have nothing to do with Sam
Harris at the moment
okay after we're going to do a Q&A this
week um you can ask questions at
Darkhorse
submission.com and uh we want to just
share with you some merchandise we'll
talk about it more at the end as well
but uh Zach's going to show our new
store here we got all sorts of fabulous
designs include have we even talked
about blueberries blueberries because
oxident happen that's pretty fabulous uh
and I've been waiting a long time to see
that rendered in reality I no you you
have you tried to convince uh the the
the the
family member of a friend of ours who
does such things years ago oh this is
that's at least a 15-year-old idea yeah
yeah uh we got uh the Goliath cap we got
uh I think there's at least one more
thing Zach has queued up here to show
maybe not um okay so um there's good
stuff available at the store I never
remember what the URL for the store is
and it Darkhorse store dark hor
store.org thanks oh you're welcome um
yes and there's a Code the code is
holiday 10 holiday 10 10 holiday 10 gets
you 10% off what this is completely news
to you yes but I'm delivering it that's
the way news is the people on the news
they read the teleprompter as if they
are the authority but it's just sort of
passing we don't even have a tele
promper though you're reading your son I
am listening to the the voice in my ear
which is actually a real person in this
case yeah yeah we are so we are grateful
for that one of the many things we're
grateful for is Zachary um being real
and here MH all right um before we move
on to things that aren't
this uh we have three three ads as we
always do at the top of the hour um you
can know that if that green perimeter is
around the screen uh then we are reading
sponsored content but you can also know
that we only uh accept sponsors uh who
make products or provide services that
we actually and truly vouch for that is
true today that is always true our uh
sponsors this week are biome Sundays and
MD hearing and we have turned away more
sponsors than we have accepted so uh in
terms of what it means these are these
are things that we uh we believe in
indeed our first sponsor this week is
biome maker of knobs and OBS knobs is
deneris of a whole new type dous is
anything you use to clean your teeth
toothpaste but also powders or knobs
knobs are fantastic biome that's biome
without the e on the end B makes a
fantastic product that all four of us
now use daily there's only two of us on
screen actually one at the moment but
you can infer the others uh because they
make products and are a brand that is
legitimately focused on transparency
safety and efficacy let's talk fluoride
for a moment fluoride is the anti-cavity
ingredient in most toothpaste that you
already know about but the fluoride in
drinking water and toothpaste is not in
a molecular form that is found in nature
or that has ever been part of our diet
we talk about this a little bit in our
book um and there's ever more research
to support the idea that neurotoxicity
from fluide exposure um especially in
children is a real problem not from
biome does not contain fluoride but that
in of itself doesn't make it unique
because uh so much research is now
coming out about the toxicity of the
kind of fluoride that shows up in
toothpaste many oral care products are
now abandoning fluoride uh but unlike
comparative products knobs includes a
different and far better remineralizing
agent that's hydroxy appetite hydroxy
appetite is a main component is the main
component of the enamel in your teeth
and it's in your bones as well it has
been extensively studied in medicine and
dentistry and is as effective as fluide
and remineralizing teeth it's a kind of
a tough word to say remineralizing REM
it's not as tough as hydroxy appetite
which every time you say it makes you
wonder if you've got the word correct
well no because since I used to teach
Anatomy Labs uh hydroxy appetite came up
a fair bit so I I I became accustomed
talking about when talking about the
evolution the original evolution of um
these mineralized tissues in the body
bone um both internal and external and
and teeth so I would just point out that
um that uh knobs
should use the
slogan uh don't use fluoride it ruins
your hydroxy appetite which would
technically be true and for a small
number of people would be funny yep I I
hesitate to say this yes spilled
different oh my God all right I don't
actually really hesitate to say that
it's it it it amuses me every time you
make a pun don't know it's a different
spelling I is fairly free how it's how
you get access to the full Pantheon of
potential puns as you ignore the
spelling yeah it's why it's why spellers
find puns so irritating frankly and why
puns spell find spellers so irritating
exactly yeah yeah we'll be talking about
workplace toxicity later guys including
this this episode here yes indeed no uh
knobs uses hydroxy appetite uh which um
is just as effective in remineralizing
teeth as fluoride but is not toxic
unlike fluoride it doesn't really stop
cavities from forming it can even arrest
tooth decay once it's underway for
furthermore even most natural natural
toothpastes that are free of fluoride
still have lots of abrasive ingredients
like charcoal baking soda and eggshells
now I mean when was the last time you
chewed on eggshells in order to clean
your teeth and yet eggshells show up
among these other things in a lot of uh
toothpaste because it's imagine that
what you need is an abrasive it's like
yeah actually you don't really want to
be AB braiding your teeth that much I'll
bet you just knowing a little bit about
how the world works the reason that
eggshells show up is that not only are
they abrasive but they are also um
abundant because they are a waste
product from some things that are being
sold for other purposes you know
products that have eggs in them and so
undoubtedly they are an utterly
inexpensive way for the uh the deneris
manufacturers to satisfy the non- need
for abrasives so this is not the way
this ad usually runs but um do you
remember when we were in grad school and
at the University of Michigan Museum of
zoology that there would sometimes be
Flyers up asking for uh any eggshells
that people had um precisely because uh
the the the bird division you know there
were there were divisions for all the
major many of the major clades of of
animals in the museum of zoology and uh
I believe that um some research that
involved feeding Birds uh was hoping I
think I have this right um to increase
the calcium in the diet by feeding them
eggshells I do not recall being asked
for eggshells ever not once well
probably because you're not um as much
of a flyer reader flyer reader yes no I
fly right by those things and don't
typically read them but no I don't
recall that at all um I feel a little
bad because probably I did have some
eggshells oh I I took in some
occasionally very
occasionally lots of people swear by
eggshells in their homemade toothpaste
lots of people swear by eggshells in
their homemade yeah no I mean I can see
the logic being that the eggshells
probably um also have calcium and people
imagine that that's going to somehow
like move into the teeth although I it's
in a very fine powder I don't think it's
tremendously abrasive I don't know not
worth doing right now though
yeah all right knobs doesn't have
eggshells and um that's to the to the
good um knobs also has no sulfates
parabens theat or microplastics no BS
knobs it's right there in the name
furthermore knobs comes in the form of
dehydrated tablets which allows them to
be shelf stable without any
preservatives take a tablet chew it a
few times and brush as normal your teeth
are going to feel really fantastically
clean because they are also unlik with
toothpaste TSA has no interest in knobs
because they're tablets so if you're
flying with knobs you don't risk losing
your dous in security also biome now
makes a mouthwash that is right on brand
free of stuff you don't want simple and
effective so if you're looking for
mouthwash try biome and definitely check
out knobs at www.b better
biome.is can enjoy 15% off their first
one month supply of knobs
and the rest of that doesn't make any
sense so I'm SK well I do uh in light of
your vicious attack over my failure to
register a difference in spelling I have
to point out that you made an error in
the read there you said that a denus was
anything you use to clean
your that's not correct and you are
going to owe a correction on that one we
can do that together with my correction
in the next live stream what um
toothbrushes for example I think don't
qualify so all right that's a proof of
concept if you want to get uh into
pedantry how about your
tongue also not aen oh you're this is
good I bet we could come up with a lot
of things that yeah fingers right you're
really really out there and you're
really you're interested in abrasive you
handful of sand grass that you use yeah
anyway yeah yeah you will have to alter
the you've read this ad though and you
read that line right but
um you weren't being a a pant at the
time and so you didn't um point it out
but we
digress so you are being a pedant now I
am responding with equal and opposite
pedantry as a result of your pointing
out that hydroxy appetite is spelled
differently than appetite I guess yeah
yeah I think this is a great episode to
be um talking about workplace toxicity
don't you
think only all work accusations are
flying flying yep all right our second
sponsor it kind of feels like we're like
halfway through the episode at this
point but only one out of three ads in
our second sponsor this week is mty's
all-time favorite Sundays Maddie is
asleep in the corner not even snoring so
you guys don't even know Sundays makes
dry dog food but it's not your usual
dryed dog food this is no standard issue
burnt kibble still the standard high-end
burnt kibble that we were feeding Maddie
seemed to please her she's a librador
she'll eat just about anything and she
really likes her food what possible
difference was she going to show an
interest between her usual kibble and
which is a widely available high-end
brand and Sundays well we were wrong as
we've mentioned before Maddie loves the
food that Sundays makes she loves it if
we run out of Sundays and give her her
previous High gble instead she is
disappointed in us and in her dinner we
should be giving her Sundays not only is
Sundays Maddie's favorite it's also far
better for her than that standard burnt
kibble that comprises most dried dog
food Sundays is the first only human
grade air dried dog food air drying
combines the best of cooked and raw
approaches like raw air drying preserves
nutrients and taste better than the high
heat meth methods better than raw though
Sunday's unique air drying process
includes a kill step which kills
pathogens so unlike freeze dried raw or
frozen raw dog foods there's no food
safety or handling risk for Sundays and
it's got the advantages of kibble and
that it's easy and it doesn't smell uh
combining the nutrition and taste of all
natural human grade foods with the ease
of a zero prep ready to eat formula
Sundays is an amazing way to feed your
dog there's no fridge no prep no cleanup
no gross wet dog food smells total
pleasure for the human interacting with
it which is a bonus Sunday also has no
artificial binders synthetic additives
or other garbage or um eggshells I think
right yeah um all of Sunday's
ingredients are easy to pronounce and
healthy for dogs to eat now eggshells
are easy to pronounce though yeah yes
yeah hydroxy appetite maybe not so much
in a BL taste test Sunday's outperformed
leading competitors
4020 and our own little anecdote Maddie
our Labrador supports that results not
so little but definitely an anecdote she
bounces and Spins and leaps in
anticipation for a bowl of Sundays way
more than for her previous food do you
want to make your dog happy with her
diet and keep her healthy try Sundays
we've got a special deal for our
listeners receive 35% off your first
order go to Sundays
forogore or use code Darkhorse checkout
that's s n d y s f r do OJ
s.com Darkhorse switch to Sundays and
feel good about what you're feeding your
dog now to fend off any potential
pedantry I would point out that Sundays
can be used as a denus it's not a good
one but unlike a toothbrush it um it can
be a denus in and of itself all right
our final sponsor is MD hearing
aid looking up Denis
okay I think you will find this is true
uh our final sponsor is MD hearing aid
we have friends and family who have
hearing loss there's a good chance that
you do too while we don't have need for
hearing aids ourselves we have a good
friend who does we asked her to assess
MD hearing Aid's newest product
carefully and honestly her testimonial
is at the end of this ad MD hearing aid
makes high quality simple and effective
hearing aids for a tiny fraction of what
most hearing aids cost helping bring
audio Clarity and capacity to people who
might not otherwise be able to afford it
MD hearing aid was founded by an n
surgeon who made it his mission to
develop a quality hearing aid that
anyone could afford he kept the price
Low by removing several rarely needed
components MD hearings Neo model costs
90% less than Clinic hearing aids and
the Neo is MD hearing aids smallest
hearing aid ever it fits inside your ear
and no one will know it's there MD
hearings products also have a have
rechargeable batteries that last up to
30 hours and their volt plus model is
water resistant in up to 3 ft of water
you don't need a prescription which also
means there's no middleman here is the
newest testimonial from our friend who
has substantial hearing loss and who
relies on hearing aids we asked her to
try this product and here's what she
said quote I tested the neom MD hearing
aids new inear Canal hearing aid I was a
bit skeptical since I've never liked the
inear canal models preferring the
stability of over-the-ear sets while
they were surprisingly Comfort they were
surprisingly comfortable and stable say
sorry never read this before staying put
without coming loose even when I wore
them to exercise I tried the Neo in
several situations from Discord voice
chat to in-person conversations in a
room with white with a white noise
generator and they passed every test
it's true that they don't have the
individual audiogram programming and
smartphone integration of my usual
hearing aids but they have everything
else for less than 5% the price they
provided an absolutely stunning level of
quality for pennies on the
end quote if you want MD hearing aid
smallest hearing aid ever go to MD
hearing a MD hearing.com sorry not MD
hearing a MD h a r i n.com use the promo
code Darkhorse to get their new
$297 when you buy a pair
offer head to mdhearingaid.com and use
promo code dark course to get their
brand new
$297 when you buy a pair offer it's it's
a fabulous deal for a fabulous product
you're looking at me like I have just
had a flare up of Dyslexia which I full
well know happened but nonetheless I got
there in the end I think the message was
conveyed and the authenticity in the
dyslexia is
undeniable it is undeniable yes I don't
know who would want to deny it but even
if they wanted to they'd be unable so to
your
point that dried dog food May a dous
yes I didn't claim that it was going to
work uh I have looked up I have looked
up four definitions of denus online yes
uh and I you don't need to show my
screen here Zach but um I've got
um I've got on um
dictionary.com deneris noun a paste
powder liquid or other preparation for
cleaning the teeth so that suggests it
was created before cleaning the teeth
but I don't know this is I mean deneris
is a human construct so let get you did
this to
yourself uh vocabulary.com
um
says denifer is a fancy word a substance
for cleaning the teeth applied with a
toothbrush it specifies that would be
hard to apply kibble with a toothbrush
to your teeth hard but not impossible
okay um we have at maram webster.com a
powder pter liquid for cleaning the
teeth again for and then um where we
should have started and I was going to
just read this one the OED the OED says
the first known use of the word denus
was from in the 16th century 1558 in
fact and it has a powder or other
preparation for rubbing or cleansing the
teeth semicolon a tooth powder or
toothpaste also applied to liquid
preparations so I feel like there has to
be int attention yes to clean the teeth
I saw you coming a mile away when you
made your pedantic snarky point about uh
are forcing you are forcing me to level
up my pedantry and I will point out that
you do not know what the intent was of
the the people that made Sundays and it
may have been that they were intending
to create a denti RIS it turned out it
was a marvelous dog food and so they
switched categories we don't know that
that didn't happen I mean I don't want
to help you out here but I can imagine
but I do feel like Yes actually um as
much as many dry dog and cat
preparations are considered not optimal
uh because not so much for dogs in
general but because cats um being desert
creatures aren't inclined to drink they
tend to get uh their liquid from their
food so if you're giving them food from
which the liquid has already been
extracted you're likely to end up having
like kidney problems and your bre
problem problems with these cats down
the road uh so one of the advantages
however of dry dog and cat food is that
it does in fact help remove plaque from
the
teeth wow you are helping me here yeah
no this is awesome I believe we've made
excellent progress on a puzzle that most
people didn't even realize was an
important I still don't know that it
exists at all yes but also with three of
those definitions at least I believe
knobs didn't fall into them because it
said a a what was it a liquid powder
paste or liquid it's it's a it's a
powder it's a compressed powder it's a
it's a compressed powder yeah
arguably okay so if we team up on him
hisry I think we got this he doesn't
even have a camera for one thing his pet
his pedantry is derivative of ours and
therefore we are way much younger we
have so many more years on we have the
the uh proper wisdom to deploy pedantry
he will not see coming no he won't no
all right happy 200th episode man yeah
it's cool now that we're the only ones
here because everybody has switched to
some other podcast yes guaranteeing that
we will not make it to 210 yes yes uh
was a good run yeah wow my scarf is
falling off okay um Let's Talk About Sex
equity for infant care shall we you know
I'm looking forward to this yeah uh so
this this comes up because I uh a couple
of episodes ago I talked a bit about uh
having been at the genp conference and I
gave a talk there about sex differences
and one of the pieces the the sets of
data that I talked about is one of my
absolute favorites and I'm not going to
go into it now I'll probably um publicly
discuss it at some point but um work
from 1973 um by Anthropologist Murdoch
and provos work that you are familiar
with me having taught with a lot when we
were at Evergreen um in which they um
did not do original anthropological
research of their own but went into the
anthropological literature um and said
okay what are uh I think it's like 50 uh
jobs that people do in in pre-industrial
cultures what are 50 jobs that people do
and uh and they looked at I think it was
185 cultures and they said for each of
them for each for each of those 50 jobs
and of course there's a lot of jobs that
are only done in a subset of of cultures
um are those jobs entirely done by men
mostly done by men it's kind of a wash
uh mostly done by women or entirely by
women and so they have you know these
five columns
50 um 50 tasks and the reason that I
Love This research so much um is that it
reveals just a number of things about uh
and you know you end up using the word
gendered here even though I generally
try to avoid the word gendered but um
once upon a time it was just a word with
the meaning in fact the early '70s it
was it was just perfectly fine to use it
totally um so some work um across
cultures is highly highly gendered um
the hunting of marine mammals when it is
done in those cultures where it is done
it's done by men right the smelting of
ores the um chopping down of giant trees
this is work that is when it is done in
a culture pre-industrial cultures uh
done entirely by men there are fewer
items there are fewer tasks uh in this
list by Murdoch and Provost uh that are
entirely done by women but that is I
think because they have excluded from
their list of jobs those things which
are anatomically or physiologically
mandated to be done by women and there
really isn't that much that is um
considered a job that is anatomically or
physiologically mandated to be done by
women so I mean by men so you know
gestation and lactation are off the
table uh and uh while there are things
like uh the preparing of vegetable Foods
uh which in most cultures where it is
done which is almost every culture um it
is mostly done by women it's pre again
pre-industrial cultures um it is not as
much a highly sexed or highly gender
task as those things like hunting of
maren mammals and chopping down of giant
trees and smelting of ores is a highly
sexed task in the other direction all of
that is sort of as you would
expect uh but where it gets interesting
and this is maybe I'll come back and and
actually do a full presentation on this
but where it gets really interesting to
me is how many tasks are in an
intermediate State meaning
uh
meaning nothing to sneeze at nothing to
sneeze at um either uh that uh there is
just no gender split at all my goodness
the dog has gotten something into her
nose um there the tasks that are just
done sort of by whomever um feels like
doing them across many cultures um more
interesting yet though is that there are
a number of tasks things like um um
weaving uh that is very very often
highly gendered uh in those cultures
where it is done but which sex does it
is highly variable and so this to me
demonstrates simultaneously the utility
of the division of labor and the fact
that many of the things that we divide
labor around aren't because men or women
are inherently better at them but
because men because male versus female
is the most obvious basic way to split
Humanity in two and say okay you know
what we got to get some work done here
you do this you do that okay I need I
got two jobs okay dudes you're going to
go over and do the weaving and women
you're going to do the you know
harvesting of crops I'm just making
those things up for a particular um
culture right so um this was sort of the
the the last thing that I talked about
in my talk and uh I got a lot of
feedback including from some people who
weren't there in the room but who
watched the live stream of the talk
including from the lead author on a new
paper um and uh who who said to me in uh
in her email to me and who s the paper
said I cannot believe that this work is
necessary um but I and several
co-authors have uh written an article
called uh breastfeeding and infant care
as sex care work reconsideration of the
three Rs to enable women's rights
economic empowerment nutrition and
health and that was published in the
Frontiers and public health um this year
which apparently this paper was felt
necessary because there was a push for
sex equity for infant care so let me
just read a little bit from the abstract
from this paper and then uh the
paragraph that um that that really
reveals what what the crazy is and again
this paper is pushing back against the
crazy but it's the kind of paper that
you know shouldn't have been necessary
at all uh let me see if I I keep on
dropping out a full screen here okay
here we are um so again published in um
last month month of this year October
um and I'll just read the the abstract
to start women's lifelong health and
nutrition status is intricately related
to their reproductive history including
the number and spacing of their
pregnancies and births and for how long
and how intensively they breastfeed
their children in turn women's
reproductive biology is closely linked
to their social roles and situation
including regarding economic
disadvantage and disproportionate unpaid
work recognizing as well as reducing and
redistributing Women's Care and domestic
work known as the three Rs is an
established framework for addressing
women's inequitable unpaid care work so
this is I went and looked that the UN
has been talking about the three hours
forever like the three hours is
definitely like a big thing in public
health and um and division of labor um
research however the abstract continues
the care work for breastfeeding presents
a dilemma and is even a divisive issue
for Advocates of women's empowerment
because reducing breastfeeding and
replacing with commercial milk formula
risks harming Women's and Children's
Health it is therefore necessary for the
interaction between women's reprodu
biology and infant care role to be
recognized in order to support women's
human rights and enable governments to
implement economic employment and other
policies to empower women in this paper
I'm not going to read all of this but in
this paper we argue that breastfeeding
like childbirth is reproductive work
that should not be reduced and cannot
sensibly be directed directly
redistributed to fathers or
others that should be so obvious right
um and and again um the lead author on
this paper sent this to me saying I know
this should be so obvious I can't not
believe we're here but we actually have
to push back against this attempt to you
know one of the three Rs to redistribute
the work of feeding
infants uh to fathers and so let me
scroll down here to a paragraph that
reveals some of some of the crazy that
they're pushing back against uh it's on
page six I think here we
go the impact on breastfeeding of
societal expectations that mothers and
fathers should share infant care equally
such as in Scandinavia should should
also be considered in Sweden parenting
handbooks position breastfeeding as a
gender equality problem and describe
breastfeeding as alienating fathers
because it distances them from newborns
and makes them
unimportant research from Norway found
that some fathers felt jealous of the
mother child relationship and sad and
excluded when women
breastfeed they describe breastfeeding
as positive for children but negative
for them while one way of coping with
this exclusion was doing more non-infant
care work another way was withdrawing
from their partner and child
it is noted that breastfeeding as an
embodied in sex practice presents a
barrier to societal Ambitions for sex
equity and child caregiving given the
importance of partner support for
breastfeeding exclusivity and
continuance promotion of the idea that
fathers should be equally involved in
infant care may undermine breastfeeding
communicating with fathers about the
special nature of the sex care work of
breastfeeding and their important role
in supporting breastfeeding undertaking
other care work May assist them in
adjusting to fatherhood and increase
their other care work and breastfeeding
rates or they could just grow up mhm
um I
have I mean that's incredible right that
that some number of men apparently in
Scandinavia are feeling excluded and
wounded um by observing uh that their
partners and the mothers of their
children are feeding their children um
when they are tiny babies it is a it is
a psychological disorder it is a
psychological disorder a psychological
disorder Maybe it's minor I don't know
but the point is the idea that anything
other than um that's kind of on you cut
it out is required here is stunning it
is it is utterly stunning so uh the
first reference in this paragraph uh
which uh is after the
sentence um in Sweden parenting
handbooks position breastfeeding is a
gender equality problem and describe
breastfeeding as alienating fathers
because it distances them from newborns
and makes them unimportant
the reference is this
one published in the Nordic Journal of
feminist and gender research sounds like
a heavy-hitting journal in published in
2021 in article called bodies get in the
way breastfeeding and gender equality in
Swedish handbooks for new parents so let
me scroll to just the one bit of this
that I wanted to share with you all if I
can find it where is it um oh oh oh I
was just going to read the abstract
there it was um excuse me this article
offers an analysis of three popular
Swedish handbooks for new parents
written by authors in the media
class itself questionable okay in these
texts breastfeeding as a gendered
embodied practice collides with the
Swedish ideal of gender equal
parenting Evolution has collided with
the Swedish ideal of gender equal
parenting okay so I would say uh when an
Unstoppable Force runs into something
stupid and soft-headed the stupid and
soft-headed thing should get the
out of the way is that I would think
especially when the stupid soft-headed
thing is written by authors in the media
class the media class the media class
the analysis explores the various ways
that gendered bodies gendered parental
rights and gender equality figure in the
handbooks drawing upon feminist studies
of bodies and embodiment and of
breastfeeding in particular it
contextualizes the primary text in terms
of the Swedish ideal of gender equal
parenting and in terms of current
breastfeeding practices in Sweden in the
handbooks the breastfeeding imperative
is resisted because it is irrelevant and
constraining for women but also because
it alienates fathers from infant feeding
breastfeeding is ultimately rejected for
reasons grounded in differences between
gendered parental bodies and particular
understandings of gender equal parenting
we contend that the book's suggestion
that breastfeeding be rejected in the
name of Parental gender equality while
it may cause women to feel physically
free also supports fathers writes
discourses and in fact serves to once
more marginalize women's bodies straight
and
queer wonderful this does seem like
progress yeah
so mostly I wanted to share this so that
we could be aware that this is happening
that there are smart people good people
in the medical field who are finding it
necessary to push to to publish to do
research and
publish work that says the obvious that
breastfeeding is sex work and it is good
for the baby and if you're a dad and
feel excluded you got to grow up and get
over
yourself the idea that uh you know
feminist discourses are going to be
supported by the fact that some fathers
feel bad at observing that the mothers
of their children have a tighter
anatomical and physi ological bond with
their babies when they are very young uh
is adding insult to injury really it's
adding you know it's adding mental
illness to an argument that already
makes no sense so how does that make
anything stronger well it does a couple
things
one um you know we talk uh in our book
and elsewhere about the difference um
between we just draw draw a distinction
between the sacred and the shamanistic
yeah the idea that the relationship
between parents and Offspring should not
be placed in the category of sacred
meaning do not mess with this that you
need um a reason of a very high quality
the the fundamental importance of this
relationship is so great and your
inability to know what all the various
you know just as breast milk yes it is
food but that's not the only thing it is
it's also carrying messages and there's
a bonding ritual so saying well hey I've
got this bottle of food and it's
technically got all the stuff in it that
it needs doesn't begin to get at all of
the things you're disrupting that you
haven't even spotted yet right so
there's an inversion of guess what the
purpose of life is to produce a Next
Generation that is as strong as possible
because you don't know what they're
going to face so upending that because
some males are feeling left out like no
that's not a good reason to experiment
it's just not I don't care if you're
feeling left out this isn't about you
this isn't about you that's really the
point that that that is precisely the
point and I feel like you know that is
something that um needs to be said to
lots of people a lot of the time now you
know in including um Sometimes women who
are demanding equity in certain
workplace situations like you know you
shouldn't be shooting for the same sex
ratio as is represented in the
population
and and unless you can find uh obvious
ways that you are being excluded for no
good
reason then shut up already this isn't
about you there is work to be done there
is work to be done and maybe the work is
um growing a baby and maybe the work is
you know smelting of ores um but across
all of these spaces there is work to be
done and the whining of someone who says
yeah but I have a I have a thing that I
want to bring up here maybe and maybe
not maybe it's not about you yeah it's
not about you is the you know the thing
that needs to be said to the the
audience that is demanding this but
something needs to be said and you
know there is no academic term for that
sophistry we don't have to answer it
right you have made an argument that may
be technically hard to respond to but it
is so obvious that it does not demand a
response that we're not going to offer
you one that at the point we agree to
sign up for the argument we lose right
right and this is now an across theboard
problem and I would point out it's um
ridiculous in this context it's just
obviously ridiculous this is why I
wanted to bring it because it's so
obvious here so obv very often not as
obvious why w't you talk to me I'm I how
could you not talk to me about this
because you're making no sense and
you're wasting my time and I would be
wasting everyone else's time if I chose
to have this conversation with you but I
I want to point out that it's a totally
different topic completely different but
the same
uh meta issue is underlying it when we
talk about the issues surrounding um the
testing of pharmaceuticals and uh
their health impacts whether they are
you know efficacious and safe and um I
was recently in a meeting of the uh the
Florida public health Integrity
committee which is composed of people
all of whom I like and respect every
single person on it is um good bring
something something unique to the table
they're all highquality minds and uh you
know they were put on it because they're
forthright and courageous and they say
important things but we find ourselves
in these discussions where it's these
people are having their time absolutely
wasted pointing out how the system could
be improved in order to make sure that
the drugs that emerge into the market
are actually safe right now I said to
them the last time I said look everybody
here is either a an academic or a
recovering academic and so you're all
subscribed to this obligation to a
certain level of rigor and precision and
all of that but obviously this group
could spend one afternoon and describe a
system that would work better than the
one we have it's not that it's not
obvious what it needs what needs to be
done to fix it it's that there's this is
the solution to someone else's problem
we're dealing with corruption right so
you know it doesn't make sense to
respond as if the system doesn't
understand that if you have a drug
company test its own drugs that what
comes out of that test is not actually a
reliable indicator of safety yeah right
yeah it's not a maybe they just haven't
seen the problem oh they haven't
realized that there's a feedback loop
and that that opens the door to
corruption no corruption is the point
and we're responding like it's an
analytical problem like they haven't
noticed the issue but like no that's not
the nature of the problem and this isn't
either this is a this is a full frontal
attack on reason yeah and it is an Inver
I it is it is feeding a you know a
narcissism that you know would have some
degree of uh breadth in our society but
it is being Amplified by people saying
oh no the birth process you know this is
about you right and if you're feeling
left out then by all means this is this
this is society's obligation to correct
this imbalance in uh in the the raising
of children and it's insane because it's
going to result and it already is of
course resulting in damaged kids well
some of what you say there I think is
super Critical with regard to when when
the when these
people um for lack of a better group
identity when these people make claims
that are so patently batshit crazy but
they do so in the language of analytics
they do so in the language of scholarly
discourse and care and it's well cited
and referenced and they have the right
you know organization of the papers and
such
almost all of us who are also as you say
academics or recovering academics are
just you know familiar with what it is
even if you know plenty of people um
have have not been in the sphere
themselves but are very well familiar
with what it is to be scholarly in all
of this feel an immediate obligation to
respond in kind because we were told and
uh if everyone is playing by actual
legitimate rules this is true that um if
an argument comes at you that uses a
framework that is carefully referenced
and is ordered in a way that you can you
like wait what was the point oh I know
where to find it and so it's it's you
know it's organized in such a way that
it is easy to figure out where the flaws
are which should be the way that things
are organize not to obscure the flaws
but to reveal the flaws because that is
what everyone who makes arguments should
be interested in having other people do
find the flaws on what I'm saying I'd
like to be saying something more true
than what I'm saying right now so if the
thing if I if what I'm saying is in good
faith um and I present it to you present
it to you in a particular way um then it
is a matter of both respect and Clarity
that you respond in the same kind of
format um with the same kind of clarity
with the same you know that you like if
I say but I've got these references here
that claim this you know why why are you
ignoring them you might say I don't
think those are good references here's
why right you can't just just say no
actually here's a unicorn right right um
but the difference is that the the
language the like the shell this the
skin suit of Academia is being warn by
all sorts of people who aren't actually
doing analysis and the rest of us go oh
God that looks like analysis I got to
respond analytically and and no we
shouldn't have to yeah so this is
exactly in keeping with what I'm saying
I just want to flip it on its head the
point is when you find yourself
responding to transparent sophistry that
is indication that what you are dealing
with is sabotage MH and this is not
inobvious at this point in fact you know
um James Lindsay has explored at Great
length you know the intellectual
background of the sabotage movement
right it was designed as sabotage and it
is now being deployed as sabotage and
whether or not the people writing these
nonsense papers know that that's what
they're involved in it is and this so at
his talk at the same conference and this
is something I I quote him as saying a
couple weeks ago in Natural Selections
you know the the phrase that he has
begun to use is the thing is not the
thing the thing is not the thing um
you're going to think you're fighting
about race about gender about covid
about Ukraine about Israel the thing is
not the thing the thing is the
revolution is how he finishes that right
which is uh exactly correct and what I
would say is you're you're dividing at
good faith is exactly correct the system
the academic system assumes good faith
it assumes that nobody is trying to
obscure the truth that every we disagree
but what we disagree over is what is
likely to be true or what direction the
truth lies in but that we are all
supposed to be agreed on the idea that
it would be a good thing to figure out
what is true that's not true we now have
a university filled with people who are
not interested in finding University
system filled with people absolutely it
is absolutely filled with people who are
trying to hide the truth
and there is no mechanism I mean
literally we have dozens of academic
terms for ways that we describe
something when you write a paper and you
uh say you claim a point and you give a
reference right here's how I know that
uh species numbers go up uh as you uh as
latitude goes down okay um so then I
will give a reference for that and then
I will say but see mhm and I will point
to the person whose work suggests the
opposite I'm not compelled by this but I
want you to look at the evidence that
goes in the other direction and I'm
going to show you where it is right
that's me acting in good faith showing
you my argument and telling you the best
evidence which does not compel me is
right here we have that we have personal
communication ah I know somebody who
works in a laboratory they're wellp
published but they haven't published
this thing yet but they told me this so
I'm going to use it as evidence and I'm
going to tell you it's not in a paper
you can read yourself but this is the
person I got it from right we have a
dozen of these things we don't have a
language for uh cut that out right
cut that out you're not no I don't
have to site you that was garbage I'm
not answering that question because you
know as well as I do that you're talking
nonsense right we don't have that
there's no immune system in this because
it's not designed to have um sabots on
the inside and the point is it can't
function this way it can't function this
way and you're going to get academics
like talking themselves blew in the face
about you know about the fact that maybe
uh we ought to think of uh the
production of babies as about
reproduction and therefore the baby
might be Central not the father's you
know resentment right
so at some level we have to start
responding to the with whatever
the academic version of no I'm not
obligated to answer that because you
know frankly you're embarrassing
yourself for even offering it as an
argument yeah um and I don't know how we
get there well and you again
this we keep on in anytime we end up
talking about um male female space uh we
see in the so-called scholarly
literature uh an implicit argument of
symmetry of well but men do this
therefore women do this well but women
um you know do this at this rate
therefore men should be doing this at
this rate and the fact is that we can we
should be we must be we are equal under
the law without being the same and this
you know this this has been an error
that was kind of
lowlevel um in some academic circles for
a while the idea that uh in order to
escape from some of the restrictions of
of Womanhood uh that women needed to
basically act just like men um most
smart people have long since abandoned
that as as an answer uh to the problems
but um now we seem to be moving towards
well but if men feel bad then maybe the
baby shouldn't be fed from the mother's
breast and also you know go a step more
insane and well if men feel like they're
women and they want to feed babies then
they should take a lot of drugs so that
they can produce some kind of sludge
from their chests and and feed babies
with it like also no also really really
no yeah everything down this the point
is that's a dead Branch yeah the fact
that you're even hunting down it is on
you yeah right like this is It's you
want me to create a landscape that makes
sense where you have centered yourself
it's it's an entirely narcissistic
landscape like no you don't like you
don't get us to use our intelligence and
analytical skills to reify your
narcissistic landscape and in fact um
once upon a time we understood the
asymmetry of this right Time's Arrow
time goes in one direction right the
point of parents is to produce children
the point of children is not to
reinforce parents right children are
you're supposed to spend to embolden to
uh to make robust to empower your child
that's the natural order of things and
then they will do it for their child and
they will do it for their child Etc
that's how things work and the idea that
anybody is playing with reversing this
is like well how dumb would you have to
be or you know what are you going to
play with next like you know uh hitting
your thumb with a hammer you know that
would be about equally as dumb right
maybe it's even less dumb maybe you
should start with that one and you know
see how that works out I think some of
them probably
should for the rest for the rest of what
they're going to do instead of
experimenting with it is they're going
to demand that we do it and then a lot
of academics who can't figure out how to
say that's dumb are going to try it I
guess I got it yeah I guess I got it
because it's in this paper in this
journal with this impact factor whatever
right um but I I also it it's a whole
new meeting on impact
factor exactly impact factor it's like
the the next generation of Fear Factor
and we'll see who the next Joe Rogan is
going to be but um anyway oh man I
there's a part of me that you know I I
can't say I've studied it that I know
anything about it other than it has
struck me as insightful and important
and it keeps recurring in my thinking
yin-yang right yinyang to the extent
that your culture contains this
shape and that you come to know it as
like Bedrock foundational uh unit of
your mental architecture is important
because what it describes is is
complimentarity and although even the um
diagram which is essentially it is
perfectly symmetrical in a way that is
actually mathematically slightly complex
to describe um right
it's yes yes it is it is perfectly it is
perfectly symmetrical you can black
pixel white pixel right well so you're
saying it's bilaterally symmetrical
that's the question is what it's not
radially symmetrical it's neither and
the point is but you can tell that
they're mathematically speaking it is
perfectly symmetrical in some way that
you and I struggle for because because
in our tradition it doesn't exist we
have to borrow it from the that kind of
symmetry doesn't exist or what it
doesn't exist it does not exist as a
fundamental piece of our education right
the the complimentary dualism right and
so the point is I even find the fact
that the name is not yinyang it's
yinyang not perfectly symmetrical right
so anyway the point is if you have
something in your culture deep in your
culture that speaks of complimentarity
at a level that there is a symbol when
you want to speak of complimentarity you
have one it's as ingrained as any
character in your alphabet right
everyone has access to it and so the
ability to say you know that um male and
female
are perfectly complimentary oh do you
really mean perfectly yeah I mean
perfectly right would have to be
that's how we got here that's how you
know that's how we end up I guess a
billion years down the road from the
invention of these two things is maybe
two yeah maybe two but whatever at least
a billion so that perfect
complimentarity you think you know
better because you have a PhD in some
field that barely exists I mean no you
don't you don't this is just simply what
we are and the fact that you think
you've got something clever to say um no
actually what you're saying is insane
and the idea that your particular brand
of insanity is going to manifest as an
experiment on children on the normal
process of raising children who the
do you think you are why are you getting
to experiment with that no this is about
this is about children it is not about
academics and it's not about uh fathers
who are butt hurt over not being able to
breastfeed it's it's about children
right you mess with that last that is as
sacred as a
right that's the whole point for every
species is the production of viable
Offspring and so you know the people who
are like eager to you know get in
between parents and Offspring in some
way they're just they're these are these
are Mad
Men that's all
there yeah yeah I got another example oh
awesome this one does not involve
children okay at least explicitly we're
making PR yeah I don't know um we are
regressing less quickly yeah
something I don't I don't even know okay
um here we go you can show my screen
here Zach nature news um publishes an
article so nature news tends to pick up
from um other primary research and say
oh this seemed really big this week
nature news publishes this week or
recently toxic workplaces are biggest
reason women leave
Academia women feel driven out by
problems with workplace culture more
often than by lack of work life
balance toxic workplaces wow and I guess
I could I haven't read the paper and I
frankly can't see it from here but I'm
guessing I know who's making it
toxic uh we don't actually go there no
the orig so I I I this this is just a
onepage thing but I went to the research
it's based on and I read it and I also
read their supplemental materials which
is quite a number of pages of uh of how
they discovered what they discovered how
they discovered what they discovered
so this is uh the original research that
that nature news article is based on
called gender and retention patterns
Among Us faculty and I'm just going to
read a few highlighted sections uh and
then uh then we'll talk about it from
the um abstract they did a large scale
survey of the same faculty
of they a large scale survey um
indicates that the reasons faculty leave
are gendered even for institutions
fields and ages in which retention rates
are not so just to tease that apart yeah
yeah please do because I can't follow
what
they what that means and it's not the
main point of of this article at all of
this of this piece of piece of research
at all is um oh actually um there's a
lot of cases where uh men and women
leave Academia at equal rates but still
the reasons they leave are different
based on sex so let's focus on
that now now I I I can I can see an
argument for being interested in like oh
men and women are leaving it at at the
same rate um but they're leaving for
different reasons maybe there's
something there but it's written so
cryptically and so CT like so it's so
hidden it's like but we need to be
concerned about that like why why do we
need to be concerned about that wait I
got it no I see I'm going to write the
next paper on this one because I know
where it goes okay here's the thing um
let's say that males and females are
leaving at equal rates M um and for the
same reasons but females are leaving one
octave higher that is to say when they
describe the reasons that they are
leaving it is one octave higher than
when men describe that same reason and
that is inequitable and because it's one
octave higher they are slightly more
likely to be described as hysterical
when they do so and it is that
description uh that uh that uh I don't
even know what right no but it is it is
a it is a highly gendered pattern of
leaving that women are one octave higher
when they say the same stuff upon
leaving like I'm leaving
yeah okay so let's just share a bit more
from this from this paper and just
scroll through um for each faculty
record we assigned a gender label
algorith algorithmically using cultural
associations between names and the
binary categories of men and women
resulting in binary gender annotations
for 98.1% of faculty in our data set we
note that the Assumption of a gender
binary is a critical limitation of
algorithmic gender
labeling the
entire paper is about sex differences
yeah
okay using this you know that clown fish
can change
sex you know that banana slugs are both
sexes at once what proving the sex
binary because both at
once I'm not that's you
all
using using this employment census we
show that across the us across us tenure
track Academia as a whole women are more
likely to leave their faculty jobs and
less likely to be promoted than men at
every career agent stage but then
notably we find that the gender gap in
retention closes for assistant
professors after adjusting for academic
field however even for ranks domains and
institutions where retention rates are
similar for women and men our survey
results show the reasons that faculty
leave remain gendered implying that
faculty attrition can be gendered even
if the overall rate of attrition is not
in particular women are more likely to
feel pushed out of their jobs and less
likely to feel pulled towards better
jobs than men although faculty associate
these pushes with work life balance
issues early in their career mid and
late career faculty highlight issues
related to workplace climate
particularly aspects of climate that are
not easily measurable such as a lack of
belonging versus overt gender
discrimination so so wait wait wait
uhhuh yeah okay so they
describe the reason that women
disproportionately leave which is
feeling unwelcome not pulled towards a
higher level BL we'll talk about exactly
what the what climate is here but do
they describe the corresponding
disproportionate that given that men and
women are leaving equally and that
they've described the reason that women
are leaving have they described the
reason that men are leaving yeah so
there's they got three categories and I
will this is in the supplemental
materials they've got three categories
that where they're broad groups and then
they've got like little survey questions
that spell out a uh archaic term that
you should not be using which one three
broad
groups yeah in the broad group they
leave for different reasons yeah so in
the fem groups they
um the broad groups are um for
professional
reasons meaning like salary wasn't good
enough I wasn't getting published I felt
pushed to publish uh uh the work wasn't
rewarding to me um I mean I shall show
exactly that's what it should mean those
things uh work life
balance uh you know I wanted to spend
more time with my family I wanted to
spend time more time like actually being
able to have a family that sort of thing
right uh and then this this third thing
which women are far more likely or are
at least statistically more likely uh to
say was their reason for leaving than
men uh which is workplace climate which
again remember nature news says toxic
work environment
right that's that's the description okay
so men are more likely to leave for
professional reasons they're look
they're looking for more money uh more
prestigious institution um a better you
know Pro probably they don't say this
but I would guess that given that
academic jobs tend to be about research
teaching and governance and service um
they probably want you know more
research less teaching and service
duties you know things like that um was
there a category in there for leaving
because you identify as too smart for
this
yeah no um they do say in there in
the survey um they included they went
and and uh they gave the survey to a
bunch of people who had left Academia um
but not people who had left uh for
retirement they had to leave for
something else so I I would think that
in that group uh would include people
who left because they were too smart for
this but I wasn't part of the and
then there's also probably it's it's not
going to be a huge category but people
who left cuz they they had to go pee and
then just decided not to come back yeah
they're like you know what I'll just
like I'll put the key C under the door
I'm not I'm not going back there yeah
okay a few more few more quotes from
this uh article we find that a portion
of the overall gender gap and Academia
can be attributed to such Crossfield
differences uh EG and there's a whole
lot before this I didn't go into but
because women are more likely than men
to be faculty in high turnover
Fields
now a um there's that's important if
women end up in fields where turnover is
higher and therefore you don't know
which came first but you you also like I
don't know if the fields um have high
turnover because women are in them or
the fields have women in them um because
they're high like it's impossible to
know and they're assuming some some
cause and effect relationship that uh we
can't we can't actually imagine we can't
actually uh know rather from what
they've done um and they find I don't
highlight it here but at the bottom of
the left column on screen here in
addition we find these disparities are
larger in non-stem domains than in stem
domains that is to say you know all the
all these fields that include all the
madeup crap that didn't exist 40 years
ago are the fields where women are
likely to um be over represented
compared to men you know compared to a
one:1 ratio and those fields have a
higher turnover um in part I imagine
because they're complete and
smart people just can't put up with it
for very long right right exactly um
okay I'm not now they might be able to
retain more people if instead of a high
turnover field they started an apple
turnover field because those are
delicious yeah totally delicious yeah
um okay I'm having a hard time taking
anything academic seriously anymore oh
as as as you as you should yeah uh from
this perspective gender detrition is
driven by gender differences in the
degree to which faculty feel pushed to
leave their current position or pulled
to a more attractive
opportunity um so there I do see that
there is a difference there like I felt
like I was being pushed out versus oh
that other thing that I saw on the
horizon looked really interesting but uh
but just the stuff that I highlighted
here is to point I I began to think like
but what is any of this based on
anything that is not just feelings right
like so professional reasons I got a
higher salary I got uh more sabatical it
was a more prestigious institution uh I
from my new place I was going to be able
to publish more and thus pursue the
question I'm fundamentally interested in
like those are not feelings based
reasons right um feeling
pushed okay by whom like did they or did
you just feel that they were right so
this this is what I began to sense as I
read through this and and um and
highlighted the things I did uh a few
more here we asked faculty who left
Academia or retired uh which specific
factors contributed to that decision
group into three broad categories
professional reasons work life balance
and workplace climate workplace climate
includes stressors related to the way an
academic feels around their colleagues
including dysfunctional departmental
culture or leadership harassment or
feeling like they do not belong or fit
in their department so the word feel
actually just shows up twice there right
and then we note however that early in
the however that in the early career
women in both stem and non-stem domains
cited work life balance as often as
climate a pattern consistent with past
literature and early career pre- tenure
faculty yes because again anatomy and
physiology and um you know women are
going to feel that pressure more when it
may be time for them to start a family
if that's something they want to do yeah
right that's really freaking obvious an
asymmetry built in here but I would also
I mean this is obviously implied in in
you're raising the whole issue yeah but
given that there was no disparity in the
leaving yeah the whole idea
that this research is somehow useful
well so there are disparities in if
right there are some disparities but
overall did they find a disparity yeah
yeah overall there's some disparity in
leaving yes Direction especially later
in the career women women leave U more
than men I don't it didn't look super
strong to me um and given that they
admitted that actually uh early in the
career less stem less uh that there were
a lot of ways to sort of chop up the
data and find no disparity
um I'm not sure that there's a problem
that needs to be addressed here but yes
they did find if we trust what they
found uh they did found that there that
uh women are somewhat more likely to
leave academic jobs than men are and do
if you include everything does that
leave a residual our faculties biased in
favor of men as a result in this of
this are you asking across the board are
um faculty in the US um still biased
towards men yeah yeah how strongly I
know I don't know okay I don't know um
we obviously have some fields that are
strongly biased towards women and some
fields that are still fairly strongly
biased towards uh towards men and um and
the move you the trend is we know that
the trend is in college we've got like a
6040 female to male split among college
students uh and in um graduate schools
uh I believe if you take it across the
board you've got got um a skew towards
women and that uh in in many fields
you've got uh a high skew towards women
uh so you know that that does seem to be
changing but in part it's changing um
because it's being forced to change as
opposed to Let's choose the right people
and see what happens and this in fact um
before I get to the final thing I want
to say about this um from their
supplemental materials um my Natural
Selections this week I wrote about what
I dubbed the appeal to the noble savage
or appeal to Noble Savages fallacy
because there's an astronomer assistant
professor of physics and astronomy at
amorist who is spearheading a move uh to
rename um some galaxies and a bunch of
other stuff that was named for
mellin because he was a slaver and a
colonizer and a murderer and anyway she
writes and I shouldn't be snarky I could
I could just read her words but you know
go go check out my natur selections
piece on this um you know he wasn't an
astronomer and the indigenous peoples um
saw these galaxies first and um and you
know what are we doing naming things
after him well you know I would actually
point out that galaxies being what they
are the people in those galaxies are
probably none too pleased to have mellin
associated with them yeah and no one
asked them did they no I'm sure they
weren't asked so you know but so I I I
am pleased with this piece I you think
the uh appeal to the noble Savages
fallacy is is the is the right thing to
be invoking when people start talking
about renaming things because uh we're
applying the standards of today which we
can't even agree on anyway but the
standards of a of today to people from
hundreds of years ago um but it also it
assumes that the people who came before
were pure and you know not human right
they weren't murderers no certainly not
they weren't colonizers have you seen
the Incas uh you know they weren't
slavers yeah a lot of them were uh and
unfortunately you can see um by looking
at um this person's work um that one of
the things that she proudly describes
herself uh as and I'm just I'm not going
to give identifying features even though
you can find it um is you know um the
first person of such and such descent to
be in you know this kind of a field in
the US it's like you know how many
descriptors do we have to tack on to be
like I'm first me it's all about me
right isn't it all about the astronomy
like aren't we supposed to like aren't
you an astronomer you're supposed to be
caring about the stuff that you
supposedly were hired to do but instead
we have amoris college who hired this
person now stuck in this landscape of
well actually you presumably hired this
person in part because they were
claiming all that stuff about their sex
and their race and their you know
lineage um being you know making them
really super prepared to do astronomy
and now what are they doing they're
trying to burn down astronomy instead of
doing astronomy so it is it is evidence
of sabotage and I just want to point to
one mode of sabotage that I think is
here and it's it was also in um the
story we talked about last time about
the renaming of birds um right you know
and the utterly maddening um well the
melenic P penguins are presumably on The
Chopping Block as well well sure um
but if you make the argument that
anybody who is compromised by perhaps a
moral
defect uh cannot be associated with a
creature or a structure in the universe
or a Township or whatever it is that
you're going to rename you make it
impossible you make it increasingly
difficult and eventually you make it
impossible to go back and reconstruct
history right just the same way um you
know Rolling Stone and the New York
Times both published that um Chelsea
Manning had given documents to Julian
Assange not true Bradley Manning did and
then Bradley Manning uh went through a
gender transition in captivity while he
was
incarcerated so if you wanted and I the
first time I read about Chelsea Manning
and I did not know that there had been a
gender transition I was
like that's odd is this person a sibling
of Bradley Manning and there was no disc
because it was like oh actually here's
the truth about transition when a person
transitions they are simply becoming
their true self which means that they
were always Chelsea Manning which is why
the New York Times and uh Rolling Stone
reported that this person was Chelsea
Manning because it was really Chelsea
Manning even though at the time she went
by Bradley so but my point is the
ability to even go back and reconstruct
history is disrupted by the renaming to
I don't know even know what the
justification is to prevent people from
feeling hurt or something but oh um it
detracts from the beauty of the
galaxies well I can see that actually I
take back my well maybe I don't take it
back but the the point
is if the purpose of study is for us to
become clearer headed to understand
things better than we did before to
create models that are more predictive
and allow us to navigate hurting oursel
less and helping ourselves more whatever
the purpose of understanding stuff
actually is then those who are out to
actually disrupt our ability to go back
and reconstruct the pattern through
which knowledge was acquired this is
obviously an attack on reason yep and so
how many different kinds of sabotage do
you need before you just simply say all
right maybe we should figure out who the
sabat tours are and get them out of here
so we can go back to work yeah um to the
earlier point you made uh we had a
solution to this name thing because many
women when they get married change their
names and so we use the French nay um in
you know parenthesis after the thing you
know Jane Smith nay Jones uh yep so so
that uh these people can be tracked as
the same individual even though at some
point they changed their name and uh we
don't talk about the um the maiden name
of women being their dead name right it
was just they had a different name then
and you know to some degree getting
married does change you know you're now
married you were single like it does
change your identity to some degree so
um you know and it and it's actually a
thing that can happen um as opposed to
changing your sex which people pretend
can happen so you know it feels to me
like it should be treated in much the
same way with regard to describing and
yeah and then you have these people like
um God what's his name like Veronica Ivy
this bicyclist dude um who's gone
through like three different names now
three different female names um each
more you know the names are more
egregious than the last but this is just
like you know an aggressive oppressive
brute um who's who's God some kind of
academic in some field uh and you know
it can be hard to track like if you're
not like wait is that the same that
looks like the oh that is the same
person okay so why are you changing your
name so much uh because the first time
it was because you decide you aren't the
sex that you are but um the last three
times it was something else
yeah at some level we have a right to
just
simply not be responding to not be
changing the names of creatures so that
we know who we're talking about I mean
yeah honestly like the creatures have
names for a reason and you know right
Fineman made this point Y very clearly
right the names are arbitrary that's not
where the nature of the creature is but
they're there for a reason yep um yep
yeah okay so um just get back to this
this paper uh which again
we're talking about it in part because
nature
news published a piece this week
headlined toxic workplaces are biggest
reason women leave
Academia so far I have shared with you
various little bits and pieces from the
paper that that headline is based on and
what I find is um there's not that much
difference in the leaving by sex but
even when there's no difference in terms
of um whether men or women are leaving
more
there's some differences in what they
report about why they left and uh men
are more likely to say I left for
professional reasons and women are more
likely early in career um more likely to
say work life balance which is something
we've all heard a lot about and and make
some sense but late in career um it's
this third thing that no one was talking
about until now which is um work
environment work climate so
uh I went to the supplemental material
uh uh which hold on did I get to the end
yeah um I went to the supplemental
material here uh their survey items that
they actually asked people actually I'll
scroll so you can't see so under
professional
stress um you know is that you maybe had
to produce too many papers get funding
um your institution wanted you to work
on particular topics you weren't
recognized your salary wasn't good
enough you weren't getting uh your work
accepted uh you didn't feel like your
department was proving administrative
support all of those make sense and
aren't based on
feels right um you know poor
administrative support I could see how
you your feels could be a part of that
but there's also just like you know are
there enough support staff um to do the
kind of work that needs to be done or
are you left doing things that you were
told when you were hired for instance
you wouldn't have to do for
yourself right work life stress um
associated with balancing work in life
caring
responsibilities um you know you got the
two- body problem where maybe you know
you're both in field fields that are
somewhat rarified and they need to move
and you're like I I got to move too uh
lack of time for hobbies and interests
um amount of time you have to work lack
of leave time um and then personal
issues so all of those make sense and
again some of them are um subjective for
sure but you can point to them and say
you know what I just I just wanted more
time to Surf right I just wanted more
time to actually spend time with my kids
or to you know to to think about whether
or not this is what I want to be doing
because it looks to me like if I keep
doing this forever I'm going to wake up
in 30 years and not have done anything
else right professional stress work life
stress and then climate stress the one
that we are told um that is the big
difference where women are more likely
to report these things than men the
basis again before I show you the basis
for which that nature news article said
it's workplace toxicity that's why women
leave we
have dysfunctional departmental culture
or leadership well yeah pretty much all
of them just that's Academia for you
feeling the new need to prove myself
feeling that people like me don't belong
or fit in my department right no sorry
or fit in my department feeling that
people like me don't belong or fit in my
institution feeling that people like me
don't belong or fit in my academic field
harassment discrimination how
competitive Academia is constant
criticism comparisons
rejections so the three of those that I
have not highlighted
dysfunctional departmental culture
harassment and discrimination are
plausibly not entirely subjective
certainly sometimes they are not
entirely
subjective the rest of these the basis
for which we have a nature news headline
claiming that workplace toxicity is why
women leave Academia because women are
more likely to answer yes to I feel that
people like me don't belong here and
it's just so
competitive this is such insanity
this is playing into such crazy
regressive stereotypical female tropes
about how women behave and what they're
willing to do to get their way and like
and nature news is buying into it this
research is garbage this survey was
garbage and they had under professional
stress and work life stress a number of
things that are
real and in this third category almost
nothing here is based on anything but I
just don't feel like this is the thing
for me furthermore these are leading
questions how many people are going to
say well yeah actually I didn't really
feel like I belonged now that you put it
that way yeah that is why I
left well and the problem is that um the
work if you can call it work the This
research yeah yeah like all this stuff
is designed to create a pretext for
remedies that are desired and the point
is this becomes increasingly
a welfare program where people create
scholarship for which they feel
entitled to be paid entitled to get
benefits so they are parasites on the
University system on society and what
they are producing as a result of their
parasitism is pretext for further
parasitism yes and this is this is
Midway in there it's a jobs program it's
a it is a make work program it's not
even a jobs program because they going
to get
benefits they have a nominal job but it
is a job that does not need to be done
in fact civilization be better off if it
weren't right um well it's you know it's
not like the WPA where a bunch of things
need make work you don't necessarily get
paid for I I think we're saying the same
thing we just have different
connotations for what these terms mean
for me a job Rogan is like oh I just
need to figure out a pretext for getting
paid like well this is it yeah but the
idea you know you could twiddle your
thumbs for a salary that you didn't
deserve and in fact you know people in
the tech sector talk about the huge
number of people who don't do anything
and you know people talk about the fact
that Elon Musk fired a huge fraction of
the staff and Twitter got better not
worse um so apparently they weren't
doing anything productive so there's not
doing anything productive and then there
is doing something
destructive in the very system that is
paying you to do that work right you are
a paid sabator yep and um
you know I must tell you my my reaction
overall
is this system is so broken to begin
with it's scientifically broken before
you even get to the fields that don't
really exist and are attacking science
and the scientists aren't even ready to
defend themselves and say no I'm sorry
stop messing around with sex we actually
understand this and you're not allowed
from some other field to you know lob
hand grenades in actually there are two
Sexes we know how to define them we know
a lot about what they mean
and um you know you can go have your
little discussion elsewhere but you're
not going to get us to change what we
say to students about whether there are
two Sexes there are right that's what
they should be saying but they don't so
the scientists are pitiful yes because
they won't stand up for themselves
they're too um cowardly to just simply
even stick up for the truth yep and the
sabator fields are on the March and
taking over the thing and the real
question is um look I'm sorry we do need
a university system but we don't have
one y and pretending that it is one
doesn't help and decide pretending that
you could rescue this one Rescue It
really all these cowards you're going to
free them from something and they're
going to go back to work I don't think
so I don't even think they remember what
work is I mean this is this is you and I
have said this over and over again but
people
often um say when you know various
projects about you know creating a new
University oh but you know is there
going to be demand it's like oh there's
demand there will be so many students at
an actual functioning University will
there be sufficient faculty yeah that is
what we are going to have a dir of and
yeah we need a lot more students than we
need faculty but we're going to have a
harder time getting a functioning
University filled with actually
competent and courageous faculty because
we've ruined a whole generation of
faculty and yes we're in the process of
ruining a whole generation of of college
age students as well and they're ruined
in a different way in some ways more
completely but the faculty once they're
in their little foms of their classrooms
get to completely destroy people and
they're doing it well this is a classic
it's actually worse than that because
the reason that there are not enough
people to staff a proper University
where you to start one it's not that
those people don't exist it's that if
you assume that an academic has an
academic degree then you're taking
people all of whom have been lobotomized
by the process that trained them there
are lots of smart people who could do a
bang-up job of educating people but how
would you who are you going to hire to
figure figure out who they are right
because the fact is they don't have
degrees they did other things they
actually you know they in large measure
were driven out by the idiocy of the
system as it stands and they went and
did something else some of them have no
degree at all yeah but the accreditation
process says uh you risk losing your
accreditation if you've got
non-terminally degreed people teaching
your classes I remember actually at
Evergreen you wanted to teach with a
friend of ours uh it was brilliant and
it was going to be an amazing program
but he doesn't you know he just had a
bachelor's degree and uh you know the
admin powers that be are like you can't
we we can't do this like even though
this would be one of the most
extraordinary programs that has ever
been taught no nope certainly can't nope
right so you know it's a system that is
in a death spiral because the correct
move is actually forbidden which is to
figure out who's actually still smart
right you are you were required to
search a landscape of people who um were
foolish enough to continue to sign up
the rules in an era of uh increasing
sofry
yeah
um this is just more sophistry but I'm
going to share one more piece of
sophistry from the same paper before we
move on just the very next page here
this was um you were you were showing um
you were shown table S9 from the
supplemental material just now and if I
just scroll down one more page this is
63 pages of suppl material survey data
cleaning
they did a number of data cleaning
choices made a number of data cleaning
choices including about
gender three out of the 6570 men in our
survey indicated they are transgender
men one out of the 3,480 women in our
survey indicated they are a transgender
woman and one of the women in our survey
indicated they are woman and
nonbinary while these five individuals
used the prefer to self-describe box in
order to describe their gender we also
included them in the binary gender
categories that they mentioned in their
descriptions including participants who
self-reported these additional aspects
of their gender identities into men and
women categories allows us to respect
their status as men and
women which these numbers are tiny right
but that nullifies anything else that
they have done right the point is the
fact that the numbers are tiny means it
probably didn't change things much but
they do not say in light of you know the
right thing to do would be to exclude
them but of course that would be
transphobic or whatever um so the fact
that they include them says that they
are more committed to um saluting the
correct flag than they are to actually
discovering anything and you know this
we're respecting their status as men and
women which they're not so wait a second
this I mean they're one of them but
they're not the one they say they are if
you go back to the thing that I was
saying about you start renaming stuff
and you make it impossible to actually
reconstruct history or to track a
particular creature you know because now
they have a name that nobody can say
because somebody might feel hurt about
it so you can't figure out the SC
scholarship on that creature before the
name Chang y y y right um this the idea
that we are going to include you under
the name under the gender that you self
describe means that we are no longer
going to be able to figure out anything
about sex differences this is a
self-fulfilling prophecy 100% And yep um
so the point is it's like I bet all the
people who identify as the sex that they
are not were more likely to say oh it's
about a toxic work environment right
yeah um
but let's put it this way they're
wielding an argument right about sex not
being a thing right right and then
they're going to make sex not a thing at
the level of the data right and then
they're going to say see it's in the
data right no difference between men and
women and that's who looks at the
supplemental materials 63 pages of
supplemental materials who looks there
right so anyway the point is it's
another attack on our ability to
understand even what's true right never
mind whether it's fair let's let's just
figure out what's true and then we can
talk about whether it's fair but you're
not even be able to know true first yeah
true would be first point that this is
this is the proof that once again um the
purpose of the exercise is not the one
that we all think academics has the
sabot tours have flipped the purpose
right right the purpose is to advance a
particular story and to the extent that
the truth gets in the way they're going
to disrupt our ability to even know what
it is that is correct that is correct so
um that leaves us with a difficult segue
oh God into talking about gratitude I am
not grateful for the
sabur um but it being as as we speak now
the day before Thanksgiving and before
American
Thanksgiving um we thought that we would
spend a little time talking about about
that so we are transitioning from the
sabator
divorce sort of
um into a discussion of gratitude and
actually yeah I think it just has to be
a clean break we just have to switch
mindsets and talk about the things um
for for which we are grateful which um
many people have noticed that
Thanksgiving is about the last holiday
to fall um maybe it has not perfectly
resisted commercialization when you know
can buy
a mainstream turkey and of course one
can do nothing but sit through
Thanksgiving wondering about what Black
Friday will bring um so anyway there are
attempts to encroach but it is in some
ways our purest holiday here in the US
still um and I wanted to I wanted to
start by saying um a few things about
what's on my mind um I should say you
and I have just been uh to the Czech
Republic we then went to um to Great
Britain to London uh and then I've just
gone for a stupidly brief visit to
Romania um and I was in Denver in there
as well you were in Denver uh and so
anyway we've been interacting with a lot
of uh
folks and the trip to to Romania
actually which is the most recent one
for
me um put me in contact with a lot of
folks some people that I knew pretty
well some people I'd never met um
but above all else we we are in an era
where we are
facing a level of dysfunction that we've
never seen that many of us never
anticipated even if we knew that it was
possible it was hard to imagine that we
would find ourselves here
and um there is a level
of um disappointment it's not strong
enough a word but people who should have
stood up who just absolutely didn't
um and uh there's a tremendous amount of
betrayal people who instead of standing
up or even cowering decided to um sign
up with the enemies of reason and
freedom and decency and all of that but
there are also a tremendous number of
people who have stood up people that we
never would have encountered if um this
particular passage of History hadn't
unfolded the way it did and I I was
especially remind the the trip to
Romania was for um the international Co
Summit the fourth International Co
Summit the first one I've attended um
but I was struck by meeting some some
folks
who have paid a terrible price for their
um forthrightness and their courage and
yet they still continue because it is
the right thing to do and they like we
have no choice about it right there just
simply is the right thing and if your
values mean anything your values have to
endure under incredible pressure and so
um I was talking to Ryan Cole who uh has
long been one of my favorite people in
the uh the medical Freedom Movement he's
a pathologist he's somebody uh I first
became aware of I was just watching a
YouTube video I had no idea who he was
and he was you know testifying and I
don't remember even who he was
testifying to he was testifying to some
uh governmental body or something and he
was saying such reasonable things about
um what actually threatens Health what
actual measures work to benefit people
the insanity of the covid response and I
was just struck by his eloquence and
um uh I've learned since I've now met
him a couple times in person I have
learned since that he's actually um
quite the renaissance man he's a
musician he's a farmer he's a Craftsman
he you know he's he's exactly the kind
of person that um you know there's just
an incredible depth to to what he
understands of the world and so it makes
a lot more sense of um his uh his
standing up in the face of terrible
pressure and he's faced the loss of his
license to practice he's got medical
Jeopardy and all for just saying the
right stuff and being early right
talking about the um emergence of what
are being called turbo cancers he was
talking about that very early he talked
about vitamin D and its role in um
preventing covid he's talked about
clotting disorders and um the so-called
vaccines anyway he's been uh a very
powerful force and he has just um he has
he has withstood a tremendous public
beating from the powers that be which
would really like to shut him down
because of how um how important the
message that he's delivering is and
anyway and his message is based on
empirical observation yes so it's it's
particularly difficult uh for others to
say you didn't see that you're not
seeing that when he is saying I in my
professional capacity am seeing this and
because he's a pathologist we've made
this point before but because he's a
pathologist he doesn't even have the
normal doctor experience because he has
vastly more patients he's not seeing the
patients themselves he's seeing samples
he's seeing scans and so as a pattern
emerges like oh my goodness there's
vastly more cancer of X Y or z type the
point is he's seeing it as something
much closer to a statistically valid his
sample size is orders of magnitude maybe
ORD of magnitude probably larger than
what most doctors would see absolutely
interestingly though when you talk to
him or when you see him present um the
cases are very personal to him right he
talks about you know the young woman who
has died suddenly you know he knows how
many hours after her vaccination she
dies and of what she has died and um you
can tell that he feels each of these
cases personally as if he was the doctor
in the room um so anyway uh I have a lot
of gratitude for a guy like this who
simply will not back down from what he
knows to be accurate and uh will present
it to the world whether they want to
hear it or not um that is a you know
surprising how few doctors we have an
entire profession of people most of them
screwed up and many of them now know
they did and haven't admitted it
publicly many others don't yet know that
they did um and a very small number who
you know have become familiar to us
because they they're the only ones you
know telling us what we need to know um
these people have
emerged and um I don't know they they
deserve a tremendous amount of thanks
yeah they really do yeah um I would also
point out I uh hadn't seen Robert Malone
in some time but in fact um Robert
Malone who was sort of the headliner of
the conference um I was
reminded that when he came to our house
actually before he was welln Darkhorse
was the first place that he showed up
that um he got substantial traction and
of course uh Dark Horse was demonetized
it remains demonetized on YouTube uh
that was one of the two videos uh that
YouTube went after y um we were fact
checked over things that were said in
that episode um I met for the first time
byon Bridal who actually uh was
responsible for unearthing some of the
information for which we got fact
checked we said true things and um the
fact Checkers declared it misinformation
which of course set YouTube In Motion
demonetizing us and um crippling our
ability to earn um so anyway I saw I saw
Robert
Malone and Robert Malone since the
uh last time I saw him has endured the
awarding of a Nobel Prize for a uh the
Nobel Prize was strangely narrow in its
description um but I was reminded that
when Robert Malone who I didn't know who
he was um came to our house and did a
podcast did a dark horse podcast and I
found out who he was he told me
basically what he had done and I was
disbelieving I think like many people in
the the medical Freedom Movement there's
this question about why why is the
inventor of mRNA technology on our side
here right right and he's on our side
because he's a very good guy
and the technology isn't safe right
doesn't matter that it's brilliant right
it shouldn't be injected into anybody
and Robert Malone knows it but yeah um
what I remember saying to him again
meeting him for the first time was you
know if you go on this program that's
the end of any shot you have at a Nobel
Prize you're talking about a Nobel Prize
worthy Discovery
invention and you're walking away from
it to talk here about what it actually
means and he knew he understood what he
was doing um which you know watching the
Nobel Prize then be awarded and I will
just point out for those who are paying
particular attention here it was awarded
not for the MRNA platform why probably
because then hisory history would have
to record his exclusion and then the
fact that he holds those patents and
therefore is the Discover yeah no they
of often it goes to three people it
could have gone to him as well if it was
for the platform it should have gone to
him but so the Nobel was not for the
platform it was for the it was for the
the pseudo urines which is an amazing
thing for them to have given it for for
one thing it allows them to award the
thing as if this had been a great
Triumph but the pseudo urines that were
swapped in for the uracils in order to
make the mrnas durable is actually one
of the most dangerous things about the
shop as it was delivered and so to give
a prize as if that was a good thing you
know reminds me
of um the scene in Catch 22 where
um if I recall correctly um the Squadron
has gone out on a mission that they're
terrified over
and they've dumped their bombs uselessly
somewhere um because they didn't want to
fly into territory they're going to
catch so much Flack right exactly so
they dumped their bombs uselessly and
the brass in Catch 22 decides that
that's so embarrassing that what they
have to do is give them medals for their
bravery in order to obscure the fact
that they've done this right so it's
it's the same damn thing right yeah
except dropping bombs someplace where no
one is hurt is a neutral act not an
actually dangerous act right exactly so
anyway I was I was um you know uh seeing
Ryan Cole and um and Robert Malone in
the same place and you know the feeling
of camaraderie amongst the people who
have stood up against this madness and
suffered all kinds of indignities and
terrifying losses of their ability to to
do their job um you know uh I don't know
how much I'm entitled to or allowed to
say about the awful stuff that has been
done to to byon Bridal but it's insane
what the man has faced just just it's
beyond
belief so anyway a lot of gratitude for
the small number of people who actually
shined under the worst conceivable
circumstances who are still standing up
and doing the right thing and you know
what these people who have suffered so
utterly they're actually a joy to be
around and it's not surprising right
they actually even though they have as
much reason to be bitter as anybody they
are the opposite of course right if that
was your approach to life right the
point is well okay they were suffering
but they're still standing and they uh
they Embrace Life and they um you know
they appreciate that that's just the
burden of the role they find themselves
in um
I don't remember to whom the quote is
attributed um but I watched this uh
documentary last night 20 days in Mario
poll about
Ukraine uh and at one point the
journalist I think who's making it
reports this quotation from someone and
again I'm sure we will hear who it is
who says War uh reveals people's
character and the bad people become
worse and the good people become better
MH uh and
uh I think that this is part of what you
are reporting on here this is part of
what you are uh you are seeing and these
are you know almost well certainly none
of the people you just mentioned and if
I think you know almost none of the
people whom we have been interacting
with um during covid um over covid
through all of this were people whom we
could have named who we could have
pulled out of a lineup before right and
um so that that that too is something to
say to those who can see but are
scared uh that when you do stand
up uh you it is it does reveal like you
you will lose people there there will be
people who turn on you and you will be
surprised by whom some of those are you
will and you will be disappointed and
there's no getting over that um but uh
you will also be surprised Ed by some of
the people whom you know who stand up
with you wow that's amazing and also by
all the people you don't yet know uh who
uh will begin to reveal themselves to
you um or or come to you and maybe you
know who they are uh and say yeah you
thank you and now now now you too are in
this with the rest of us and here we go
yeah and you know we've called this the
painful upgrade and it is but the degree
to
which it's just better yeah right
I
um the cost live not by lies right yeah
live not by lies and the fact is um yes
they will make you suffer that's what
they do it's how they get away with it
um but um the
ability the ability to be in a room full
of people who you you know you just
admire because of what they have endured
in order to frankly tell people what
they needed to know in order to protect
their families um you know it's an honor
to be in that context and to and to know
that you belong and so anyway there's no
getting around the fact of uh the cost
and there's no getting around the fact
of people you will lose but you're
better off without them um and you know
you will you'll be glad to join the
group of people that at the end of the
day you know who they are you know what
they stand for and um and you don't have
to feel strange about um about you
know what their weaknesses might be
right and you know in the case of those
people who have stood up courageously
and suffered the costs that when you do
come to disagree with them when you do
discover disagreement with them which
you will because there is presumably not
anyone else on the planet with whom you
agree entirely
um that they are not going to respond
with outrage and hurt and and
woundedness and act like this is all
about them or that you're an idiot for
thinking that way and you know maybe you
do have some opinions that you're an
idiot for thinking that way we probably
all do but uh you know the these are the
people who are well able to sit with
other human beings with whom they do not
see entirely eye to eye and say cool
let's talk about it
or okay we've done that for now um at
least for right now we're not going to
get any further so you know let's let's
play ball let's have dinner let's have a
campfire whatever it
is so I guess I there is one thing that
I would sort of offer to that group I
think if there's one vulnerability of
all of these incredible people and you
know to start naming names because I
will inevitably you know forget people
but uh I spent some time with Jessica
Rose who hadd never met uh Harvey re um
Denny
rort the um Marl Mass there were lots of
lots of important names from this
movement there
um
most um this was their first rodeo co co
not this conference this Co yeah Co was
their first rodeo and the problem with
that is a CO was special right it was
the most extreme one of these probably
ever the degree the breadth of the
propaganda the intensity of the attacks
the amount of money at stake made this
sort of the ultimate um battle the mass
psychosis was Global was glos absolutely
Global and actually Matias desmat was
there only briefly at the conference so
it was great to see him too speaking of
he doesn't suffer from M psychosis but
he has uh described Mass formation and
anyway it was great to see him he gave a
wonderful talk um but
the uh what I wish these folks could
understand most of them is that some of
what they are experiencing is unique to
covid and some of what they are
experiencing is generic to fighting
Power and you really need a couple of
data points before you understand that
part of this you're being misled by the
degree to which the details are about Co
maybe they're about IM Immunology or
they're about you know the funding of
medical research or something like that
and you don't realize that there's a
generic aspect to this which is that
when power wants to shut down a
narrative it does certain things and um
some of it's just generic you know so I
was talking him uh Byron Bridle for
example about the insane stuff that he
has faced at his university he's like
can you believe that my colleagues X Y
and Z it's like oh yeah yes I can
believe it because we Face the exact
same thing on a totally different topic
um so anyway that that it would I do
hope that those folks can somehow
globalize what they know and infer that
fighting Power is this thing and they
just had a very unusual first experience
well I will I can I can add to that that
I had a similar experience with some
number of the people I talked with at
the jped conference in Denver um that it
is um people experience one of these
uh sort of reversals of reason and uh
and mass
formation and um and learn that lesson
very very well and suffer a great number
of costs but it can be very very
difficult to generalize to oh maybe this
isn't the only time or the only domain
in which this is happening well and I I
guess the the
hope I think I believe you think
that the uh the powerful force that
pulled this Co nonsense on us is the
same powerful force that is on the march
on other topics you know the woke
Revolution is about something and it's
not really about you know people who
think they're oppressed rising up it's
about disrupting a kind of normal
functioning for the purpose of getting
somewhere um and so what we need is
the there aren't there AR there aren't
enough people who are ready to stand up
and fight courageously but each time
somebody does they embolden somebody
else so we need a kind of
contagious uh spread of Courage yeah um
and that requires people to realize that
their uh Partners may actually not you
know if you're a covid dissident you may
not realize that you know John mcder is
on your team too because he's on a
totally different topic right um but
it's not a totally different topic it's
people who are willing to stand up in
the face of power and actually uh speak
the truth and to that point this leads
to another category that I'm grateful
for that I think is uh is worth calling
out and I don't know how to do this
exactly but we noticed back in the um
the days of the BLM riots that one of
the things that was really conspicuous
about the
um the enemies of reason and decency was
that they were toned deaf like literally
they could not yeah couldn't come up
with a protest song that didn't sound
like like a durge you know you know it
was terrible it like hurt your ears to
hear was M God it was terrible right
it's like wow you're that unmusical um
and then you know the degree to which
there was no sense of humor those people
just no sense of humor humor is like
terrifying you know unmusical not funny
right there's just no there's no spark
of human genius in anywhere in that uh
that group so what I wanted to point to
is that something has emerged um that's
quite hopeful and uh we we haven't
released it yet I'm I'm uh we will soon
release an episode I recorded with um an
artist his name's Brad but he goes by
five times a August who has shown up as
a um he has become a person who write
songs about where we are which is not
what he set out to do his life has been
music but he was much more standard and
he became radicalized as he saw what
happened over the course uh of the last
several years and he became you know a
poet of um the folks who actually are on
the right side of History if I can use
that overused phrase um but anyway he
wrote a song um which was one of several
that caught my attention um called ain't
no rock and
roll in which he and it's emotional for
me even to describe it because of what
it must have meant to him to do it but
he calls out all of his
Heroes for not showing
up right or even showing up in the in
the wrong place yes right yeah and his
his basic point was was you know all
that stuff that you sung about you know
the man and oppression and uh you know
the failure of decency and all that
stuff was apparently and we
believed you and then you know
um uh you know there's a line in the
song where he talks about the fans take
took the blame right that the fans
effectively had listened to you know Bob
Dylan joanny Mitchell and and you know
Neil Young Neil Young all of these
people and then these people just cowed
um and so anyway I think there's
something remarkable in an artist you
know confronting his elders and pointing
out their terrible failure um so anyway
that means something to me I was
listening to that song I asked um Siri
to play that song for me in the car and
then it played another song after which
I had never heard before um which which
was also five times August um which uh I
would recommend people also listen to
called the anti-fascist blues which is a
spectacular song in its own
right I should point out I know the
second song you're talking about there
because I listen to a bunch of his music
after you recorded that podcast he's a
legitimately a good artist it's not he's
not just making activist music which
usually sucks he's great and he's he's
The Cutting Edge because but it's it's
really good and it's also not a
recreation of like music from the 60s
with new lyrics it's it's Unique to him
it's really good well in fact you may
not know this but the song The
anti-fascist Blues is musically an
illusion to the Subterranean Homesick
Blues of Bob Dylan um so it but that's a
difficult needle to thread you either
get too close to the Subterranean hums
sick blues and then it's derivative or
it's too far and then like the illusion
what does it even mean but he he Nails
it perfectly and the lyrics so the other
thing about him
is his songs all come with a video that
he puts together and the video is sort
ofes it's animations but it's you know
it's done sort of like Monty Python with
you know cutouts that move right anyway
it's done very well also very compelling
it's not a simple yeah it's not simple
simple thing to do and it contains all
the lyrics so one of the things that's
wrong with rock and roll is you often
don't know what's being sung but in this
case you watch the video you know
exactly what's being sung because it's
contained in in the video but anyway I'm
so I'm a big fan of what this guy's
doing it's Cutting Edge in a number of
different ways musically it's great it's
so poignant and and uh timely and his
interaction between the music and the
video stuff is also you know it's like
you know an opera has um you know the
score and the labretto and the point is
it's not really complete without both
things so this this is sort of like that
but often almost always with the Opera
created by different people which is
which has always seem strange to me um
because in the kind of music you're
talking about here it's almost always
the same the same people yeah or at
least it should be because the the
artist who you know who wrote the thing
also knows what it's supposed to mean
and therefore right um creates the
visuals but anyway so I'm really
appreciative of the fact that um how
shall I describe it Goliath the force
that opposes all meaningful
change has made a terrible terrible
error Goliath has
taken
every talented courageous insightful
person and it has shoved him out the
door simultanously it's put them all on
the same
team and that team faces significant
disadvantages right it doesn't have the
equipment certainly doesn't have the
institutions right it's it's at a
disadvantage but it's got all the best
people and guess what it's got the
musicians there aren't very many at the
moment that you would want to listen to
because of the collapse of you know the
music industry turns out to be just the
business and all of the people who
pretend to be Rebels aren't right so
that's tragic on the other hand the
people who are actually now pushing
music forward are on our team right
that's pretty cool and so I would point
to um you know not only Brad of five
times August but I became aware of uh
Francis Aaron and his uh I pointed you
to it you don't recognize the name but
um his song uh which is in a genre I
don't typically like um uh about humans
aren't clownfish I think the song might
just be called
clownfish anyway it also does the same
thing where the video makes it really
clear what's being sung about I feel
like you did this thing that people
usually do in like sophomore year of
college like I just I'm just going to
listen to this on repeat like 300 times
because I like right but it was
necessary to hear somebody you know
who's obviously it's it's a great song
it's a great song it's it's done the
genre is hip hop and but it's like so
intellectually incisive about the gender
stuff and I would point out that just
the cherry on top is that so the song
takes place where you know I guess Aaron
Francis Aaron is describing how crazy
this situation is but he's got a kind of
a dumb who keeps asking questions
right um when you know what about
clownfish right exactly um and but
Francis Aaron resists the obligation to
explain why it matters that human beings
aren't clownish the point is look that's
all I need to say right clownish is not
an argument because we aren't them is
you know more than actually needs to be
said already so anyway I greatly
appreciate apprciate that there are a
group of artists who are as Zach says
very high quality in their own right and
also on our team and that's not a
surprise because of course you know the
people who are really thinking for
themselves would end up on our team and
they'd also be the people pushing music
forward at a time when it has become uh
born corporate and all of that um so
anyway that's really cool now before I
move on to the next little piece of this
um something I forgot to say Brad when I
interviewed him I didn't interview him I
don't interview anybody when I talked to
him
um I don't know that I don't know that I
grilled him but um anyway a connection I
forgot I know some of the guests leave
with those black lines I was wondering
where they got those the grill marks
yeah yeah I don't
know I'm just that good um but anyway I
noticed something else a connection
which was um a Walter Kar Tweet now
Walter K is not a an artist he's a
writer um somebody that I quite like and
that you are now working with uh on uh
country Highway County High County sorry
I'm sorry Walter um County Highway which
is America's only newspaper is that
right yeah it's quite cool it's awesome
really like it I don't have a copyright
here else I break it out but uh will you
put up that tweet of Walter Kars that I
sent you you did not send me a tweet by
Walter Kern I didn't yeah so there's a
tweet you sent me but I want to make
sure we're on the same page tweet with a
video the video yeah so it's possible
that I've sent Zack the wrong tweet I
was I had my attention maybe Heather
will PR this pull this up I don't know
what you're talking about but you go to
Wal and you search for uh Rock so I have
the video and everything from so hold I
just want to show Walter kar's tweet he
he he deserves credit here so I I can't
what you want me to search for rock
within Walter Curry yes
CH
segment I gotta go into a different site
then because you can't just do that
from um so anyway Walter karna was
pointing to an event that also caught me
off guard but he summed it up quite
accurately the event
was the uh
inauguration of a state department
initiative where they were going to
basically
[Music]
use
uh hold on let's scroll down no scroll
scroll done a lot scroll there it is
there which one this that one y that one
yeah okay so show Heather's screen here
okay can you zoom in a little
bit
so
um this is secretary Anthony binkin
blinkin oh blinkin thank you
um and what this is is an event where
they are launching um an initiative to
combine music and diplomacy effectively
they are going
to um
use music to enhance their propaganda
efforts and now if you watch this video
Zach you want to play a 30 seconds of it
yeah um
yeah so from the the great Muddy
Waters and if this doesn't clear the
house I don't know
[Music]
what no keep
going so from the the great Muddy
Waters and if this
[Music]
do woman told my
mother before I was
born going to be a man child
coming going to be son of the
gun going to
make okay yeah so anyway
um we can't hear it when Zach plays it
but what they what you guys heard it and
you can tell this is a very musically
competent right this was high quality at
the level of production values um
but
soulless because these are dudes at the
state department in suits playing the
blues they didn't pay their dues
right that's the rule actually right if
you want to pay play the blues you you
have to pay your do that's that's the
relationship between those things and so
Walter Kern's tweet I thought nailed
this he said end of the rock era he said
said uh official end of the Rock
official end of the rock and roll era
Walter Kar is declaring rock and roll
dead on the basis of this despicable
event um and he's right of course he's
Walter Karr after all it's one of the
things he does
um Walter's very insightful I he
absolutely is I just I recently begun
been thinking again about the appeal to
Authority fallacy and it's a fallacy um
no this not just because most of our
authorities turn out to be idiots but
because even actually knowledgeable
people can be wrong this isn't appeal to
Authority this is appeal to track record
um so
anyway Walter declares rock and roll uh
dead on the basis of this which I think
is absolutely accurate which is also
completely concordant with uh Brad of
five times
August uh calling out the entire uh
history of rock and roll on the basis
that they were obviously lying because
if they weren't lying they would have
shown up to fight the man and they
didn't um so anyway I think that
Confluence of stuff is interesting and
I'm grateful for people like Walter uh
who delivered the Insight at just the
right moment I'm grateful to these
artists who are
[Music]
um creating you know they're they're
wielding one of the two best weapons
that we've got
right music is a very powerful weapon
for galvanizing people and uh and it it
needs to be there um and then I guess
lastly I would just also say that the
you know we also have Bob Moran who's
put together some brilliant cartoons
that have made these you know
infuriating claims by uh the powerful
has called them out in ways that are
just um incredibly incisive and then
we've got comedians like uh Jimmy door
and um Dave Smith who have also done an
excellent job of calling out the
nonsense um that we've been facing so
anyway I guess what I'm really saying is
times are rough but um if you're paying
attention if you're on the right side of
these issues if you're standing up and
you're
feeling um isolated by the fact that you
know there has been a zombification of a
huge fraction of the population uh on
issue after issue then it's kind of
marvelous to discover that you're
actually on a team with all of the most
uh clever musically incisive funny um
you know gifted people that's a good
place to be and it you know would you
want to be anywhere else I don't think
so right that's the team you want to be
on and frankly as much as we're
outgunned I kind of like our
odds hope you're right I mean I better
be all right I think that's a good place
to finish then all right
um
good uh we will be back in 15 minutes or
so with a short Q&A because we've gone
very long uh and then we'll be back in a
week uh a week I think yeah a
week uh and uh in the meantime you can
find us on locals uh we'll be doing a
private Q&A this Sunday um at 11:00 a.m.
Pacific on locals and right now the
question asking period for for that
private Q&A is open we've got our
store which uh Zach showed us some stuff
from earlier including blueberries
uh because accidents happen because
accidents happen yeah it's great
um check out Natural Selections at uh at
my substack natural selections. substack
[Music]
docomond this week biome Sundays and MD
hearing are all worth finding if you
have teeth a dog or um hearing
problems or a dog with teeth because
well all right we cover that up top I
feel like we did that's part of why we
went so long we spent all this time on
like the union between venris and dog
kibble um we are supported by you we are
grateful to you we thank you very very
very much uh we hear from uh many of you
and uh we are grateful for those for
those words as well um please subscribe
like share come over to our Rumble
Channel come over to our locals and um
until we see you next time be good to
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well everyone
[Music]